LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to "Coffee
With a Googler."
I'm Laurence
Moroney, and I'm here
today in New York
City, where I'm
meeting with Ray Tsang
from the cloud team.
Now Ray, you've been working
on this awesome project called
Cloud Spin, which is effectively
using a bunch of Android phones
and building bullet
time from the matrix.
Could you tell us all about it?
RAY TSANG: Sure, yeah,
so a team of four
us, we built these bullet
time demo called Cloud Spin.
It was actually
designed in built
for our event series called
the Google Cloud Platform Next.
And we actually
toured the world.
We went to a bunch
of different cities,
and we took this
experience to there
so that people can
actually experience
what Google Cloud can do.
So built this demo that used
many of the Google Cloud
technology that will take a
photo from 19 different Android
phones, and at exactly
the same moment of you
jumping in midair.
And then we can
stitch them together
in the Google Cloud
Platform and to form
this 180-degrees spinning photo.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's
like an animated GIF of all
these pictures put together?
RAY TSANG: Yeah,
so eventually, we
produce this animated GIF
that gets posted on Twitter,
or it gets sent through
email to the audience.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Cool, so now we
actually went to where you
built the prototype of this,
and we filmed a video of it.
So why don't we
run that video now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, I'm Brett McGowen, and
I'm a developer advocate
for the Google Cloud Platform.
One of our goals
of this project was
to use all off-the-shelf
hardware and open source
software so that anyone
could create their own cloud
spin set up.
The hardware in this room
consists of 18 camera tripods.
On top of these camera tripods,
we have special adapters
to hold our Nexus 6 cameras.
We position all of
the cameras eight feet
from the center point,
where the user is standing.
This lets the user jump
up as high as they can
and still remain on screen.
Once we've got all the
cameras set up and plugged in,
we need to align them.
We do this by taking
a marker pole,
marking it two places with
tape, and setting it where
the user is going to stand.
Then on the back
of the camera we've
got cross hairs that we can
use to align to the two points
on the marker pole.
This lets us align the view
in multiple dimensions.
Once the cameras are all
aligned, we need a volunteer.
Hi, would you like to sign
up for a Cloud Spin video?
-Sure, sounds good-- so
name, I put my email address
and on my Twitter.
Oh, cool, so you can post
it to Twitter for me.
-Exactly.
-And I'll be good, I agree
to the terms of service,
and sign up.
-Perfect.
Using Firebase, the sign-up
app will send his registration
information to our control app.
Out control app uses
Firebase to show
the status of every phone that's
connected to the Cloud Spin
system.
We'll also use our control app
to push out different settings
to the phone, such as
exposure or shutter speed,
so that as we get into
different lighting conditions,
we can control those
settings in one place
and have all the cameras
automatically update.
Now that we're ready,
we'll hit Start Countdown.
So this will send a time
stamp to all the phones
so that they know the exact
moment, eight seconds from now,
when to be recording video.
The control app has a
button called Take Photo.
When we press this,
a beep is sent out
through the audio jack
of the control tablet
and is split 18 ways to go into
the headset jack of each phone.
This will mark the frame at
the exact same moment of time
across all the cameras.
Once each camera is finished
recording its video,
it'll upload it to
Google Cloud Storage.
So we can process in the
cloud, extract all the frames,
stitch it together, and
create our final animation.
All right, step into the center,
and I'll get out of the way.
One, two, three, go.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow, that's
a lot of equipment in that.
It seems like a lot
of fun to do that.
RAY TSANG: It was
definitely fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So how long did it
take you to put that together?
RAY TSANG: So we actually
only had about three weeks
for all the development.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, it
was a very short time.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
With all the stuff
that you were doing
in your prototyping,
there must have been a whole
lot of things went wrong, right?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, so, I mean,
having three weeks itself,
it's pretty difficult
to deal with.
We also had Google I/O in
between, and not to mention,
but a couple of my teammates
actually were on vacation
for like a week, so.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They left
you to do all the work?
RAY TSANG: Well, not
all the work, yeah.
And like when we
built the prototype,
we had to use many of
off-the-shelf components,
and we thought we would
build this thing as scrappy
as we can, so that rather than
using a tripod that you saw
in the video, we started
off with other ideas,
like we wanted to
use selfie sticks.
So, I mean, you
can imagine people
holding up selfie sticks,
and forming like a circle.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So 19
Googlers all holding one up?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Expensive project.
RAY TSANG: More expensive
than the tripods, of course.
But by then, of
course, we wouldn't
have people holding it.
We wanted to sit the
selfie stick on the ground.
And as you can imagine,
the selfie stick,
it's just one pole
and doesn't really
have three legs to hold like a
half-pound Nexus 6 phone, so it
was very, very wobbly.
And you probably saw in the
video when you were there,
we have all these
cables lying around.
And it was really,
really easy to kind
of trip over one of these
cables and then just pull
one of the phones down.
And so we always have to
go and kind of trip over,
when we have to go
and fetch the phone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One
of the remarkable things
about the picture is like
it's pretty accurate where
the pictures were taken from.
So must have had to
measure it quite well
around a semicircle
with the same radius
to each camera's lens.
How did you do that?
RAY TSANG: So there are a
couple things that we have done.
So first of all, we
have to figure out
how far away the camera needs
to be from the center point
so that we can actually
capture the person jumping.
Because if you're
too close, the head
will be cut off in the video.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You don't
want that, only in the video,
though, right.
RAY TSANG: Only in
the video, yeah,
but then we had to measure
how far the camera needs to be
far away from the center point.
And initially, we
actually couldn't
find a measuring tape
in the Google office
at all to do the measurement.
And for some reason, Brett
actually found caution tapes
around my desk.
Now, I don't know why I
have those police caution
tapes around my desk,
but so he found it,
and then we measured
it with cautions.
And I think he said that we
need to be eight cautions away.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
eight cautions away,
that's the management, OK.
BRETT MCGOWEN: Yeah,
but eventually we
found like real measuring tapes,
and then we measured it out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So was
eight cautions accurate?
RAY TSANG: It was
about eight feet.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, one
of the things I noticed,
and what Brett was talking
about in the video,
is you didn't
actually take photos.
You took videos.
I know like a
video obviously has
a number frames, like,
24, 30 frames a second
or whatever it is.
So you have to pick out the
right frame from the video.
And he said you had
an audio cue for that,
so will you tell us
a little about that?
RAY TSANG: Sure, so first
of all, taking the photo
from each of the phones is
going to be very difficult
if we want to take the
photo all at exactly
the same time because
there is this random delay
in the hardware.
So when you want to take
the photo from the phone,
you just don't
know how much time
is going to wait before the
photo's actually being taken.
And if we have
these random delays
from all of the 19 phones, then
we will be taking photos of you
jumping in midair, or
where you landed already.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They
won't be synchronized.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, exactly.
So rather than doing that,
we recorded the video.
And to synchronize all of them
together, we used audio cue.
So I as the videos are rlling,
and when you're in the midair,
we generate a tone,
an audio tone,
that gets fed into
all of the devices.
And, oh, by the way, we
actually thought about doing--
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's the
Flying Spaghetti monster.
RAY TSANG: Or
whatever, yeah-- so it
was very difficult to actually
feed audio signal from, say,
the tablet that's generating
the tone into the 19 devices.
So now an audio
engineer actually
drew a schema, how
to actually build
a device that can help us
split the audio signal.
And another difficult
thing to do this
is that when you plug in the
audio line, the audio cable,
the device has to be able to
recognize that this is a mic.
So to do that, we
built this device where
the audio kind of
comes in one way,
and then we split it
into 19 different ways.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, fun.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, and we
got like these resistors
and whatever that kind of
generates the right resistance
so that the mic is being
picked up by the phone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
resistance isn't futile?
RAY TSANG: Yeah,
but unfortunately,
it is futile because this device
unfortunately didn't work.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, so rather doing
that, we actually just went
out and bought off-the-shelf
components that can help
us split the singnal.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, sounds good.
Now, one of the things
I noticed as well
is that like all
these phones, they
have to be synchronized in
when they start this video.
So they had to be
remote controlled,
and I hear you had a
really fun, innovative way
of using Firebase to do that.
BRETT MCGOWEN: Right,
so rather than, say,
building our own server
and sending our own network
signal to all of the
devices-- remember,
we only had about three weeks.
And you do something
custom to send the single
to all these devices, it's
going to take us a lot of time.
So rather than doing
that, we used Firebase.
And the way that we have used it
is to send out from the tablet
when you press the button
to start the countdown,
we actually write
the timestamp of when
the video should be starting
to recording into Firebase.
And then Firebase then
can synchronize the data
to all of the 19
different devices.
So every single device,
every single Android phone
at this moment, they receive
a signal from Firebase
with the timestamp of when the
video should start rolling,
and all the devices then
will start recording
the video at about
the same time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool,
really fun project,
you've done a lot
of work on this,
and if developers want
to take advantage of this
or do some this itself, are
there any resources out there?
Have you blogged, or do you
have source code or anything
like that?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, so we
actually have a three-part blog
series that's actually posted on
the Google Cloud Platform blog.
And we are planning to
open source the code,
so you should be
able to take the code
and put it onto the
Android devices,
or get some phones from
friends and put them together,
and you can use selfie
sticks if you want to,
and you can form a little half
circle or a quarter circle,
and can also do this yourself
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
that Firebase technique
that you used is
really interesting.
I'd love to learn, and
I'm sure developers
would love to learn
how that was done, too.
So keep an eye on the
Google Cloud blog,
and when the source code's
available, you'll post it?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool,
well, thanks, Ray,
that was a whole lot of fun.
And I had a great fun going
and building that spin.
And so everybody, thanks
for watching this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler."
If you've any questions
for me, or if you've
any questions for Ray, if
you want to know anything
about this project,
just please leave us
a question in the
comments below,
and we'll be happy
to answer them.
Thank you.